Tomemos una sección de ADN y vamos a desenrollar
sus dos cadenas. Y para recordar que el ADN es una
molécula muy, muy larga, voy a poner flechas
aquí en nuestras dos cadenas de ADN. Y la
pregunta que quiero hacerles es: si tuviéramos
que replicar este ADN, ¿cómo sería el resultado
final? Estoy pasando por alto todo el proceso de
cómo se replica el ADN y centrándome sólo en el
producto. Tenemos tres opciones. La primera es
la replicación conservativa. En la replicación
conservativa tenemos nuestro par original de ADN
y luego sintetizamos un par de ADN completamente
nuevo; podemos ver el par original que se ve
igual que el que teníamos antes en amarillo y
luego tenemos un par completamente nuevo que se
representa en azul. Nuestra siguiente opción es
la replicación dispersiva, y en la replicación
dispersiva terminaremos con dos pares de ADN,
en cada uno de esos pares tenemos algo del
ADN original y ADN nuevo dispersos dentro
de esta doble cadena de ADN; podemos
ver que hay amarillo y azul mezclados,
y no necesariamente tendrían que tener
la proporción tan exacta que dibujé aquí,
donde amarillo y azul son del mismo tamaño,
quizá haya más de amarillo o algo menos de azul
o viceversa. Y la tercera opción que tenemos es
la replicación semiconservativa. En la replicación
semiconservativa cada par tiene una cadena
original, que se ve en amarillo, por supuesto,
y una cadena nueva que está en azul. Y esta
pregunta fue respondida por dos científicos,
uno llamado Meselson y otro llamado Stahl, quienes
realizaron un famoso experimento que lleva sus
nombre: el experimento de Meselson-Stahl,
y en este experimento demostraron que la
replicación del ADN es semiconservativa.
Entonces así es como se replica el ADN.